[Música]
hoy se cumple un mes del golpe de estado
en mi amar y continúa la represión
contra los manifestantes en las calles
tan solo el domingo el día más mortífero
desde que los militares se tomaron el
poder 18 personas perdieron la vida
entre tanto un tribunal presentó hoy dos
nuevos cargos contra la depuesta líder a
un samsung chip
en eeuu el expresidente de donald trump
reapareció en un discurso desde su
salida de la casa blanca insistió en que
no perdió las elecciones y que los
comicios fueron manipulados aseguro que
no creará un nuevo partido pero insinuó
una posible candidatura en 2024 criticó
las nuevas medidas migratorias del
gobierno de bailén
un tribunal francés emitirá su veredicto
sobre el ex presidente nicolas sarkozy o
cargos de corrupción y tráfico de
influencias los fiscales alegaron que
sarkozy se ofreció a asegurar un trabajo
en mónaco para un juez a cambio de
información confidencial de una
investigación sobre pagos ilegales para
su campaña presidencial en 2007
muy buen día gracias porque tenemos con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos en mianmar donde este lunes
la respuesta líder prodemocracia en sang
soo choo compareció ante la justicia en
una audiencia virtual en la que la junta
militar en el poder tras el golpe de
estado del primero de febrero imputó dos
nuevos cargos en su contra al tiempo que
la policía volvió a reprimir las
protestas en contra de la toma del poder
de los militares un día después de la
jornada de represión más mortífera que
dejó al menos 18 personas fallecidas
veamos el siguiente informe
la líder prodemocracia aún sang soo choo
compareció este lunes de manera virtual
ante un tribunal tenía una apariencia
saludable según informó su defensa su
chip no ha sido vista desde que fue
detenida tras el golpe del pasado 1 de
febrero desde entonces está acusada de
violar normativas comerciales y
sanitarias pero este lunes fue imputada
con dos cargos más incitar a disturbios
públicos y violar una ley de
telecomunicaciones
mientras sucedía su audiencia la policía
dispersaba con gases lacrimógenos y
granadas paralizantes nuevas protestas
en el país cientos de manifestantes
salieron a las calles a pesar de la
violenta represión del domingo que dejó
al menos 18 muertos por disparos de las
fuerzas de seguridad es realmente
horrible han demostrado que pueden hacer
cualquier cosa sabemos por su historia
que su brutalidad no conoce límites
vemos que refuerzan esta brutalidad
contra los manifestantes pacíficos creo
que necesitamos sanciones más fuertes
autistas que no sólo sancionar a las
personas sino que también deben
sancionar a sus intereses comerciales y
sus diversos conglomerados el domingo
marcó un punto de inflexión en la
represión iniciada tras el golpe de
estado que ha dejado más de 1000
personas detenidas según indica una ong
local
como saben lo que está haciendo la junta
es ilegal los ciudadanos deben
protegerse
en todo el país los manifestantes
continúan exigiendo el regreso al orden
constitucional así como la liberación de
succi quien enfrentará a su próxima
audiencia el 15 de marzo
vamos ahora a eeuu donde reapareció
públicamente el ex presidente de donald
trump en su primer discurso desde que
dejó el poder en la conferencia de
acción política conservadora el ex
mandatario volvió a negar que perdiera
las elecciones de noviembre 2020 y dejó
la puerta abierta a una eventual
candidatura en 2024 además criticó las
nuevas medidas migratorias del gobierno
de joe biden para hablar sobre este tema
el cambio anunciado por la nueva
administración sobre las políticas
migratorias quiero saludar en este
momento a rafael peñalver abogado
constitucionalista abogado gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
preguntó qué tanto han cambiado las
políticas migratorias del presidente
byte en respecto a la era de donald
trump y le pregunto si podemos ver
cambios reales y radicales como los
anunciados en este corto tiempo
pero algunos días efectivamente el
discurso de ayer de tron parecía un
discurso de campaña y tocó el tema
migratorio
básicamente volviendo a tocar el hecho
de que eeuu es un país que les debe
cerrar las puertas a los inmigrantes
supuestamente aquellos que le llaman los
ilegales
la política de bailén hasta ahora ha
sido una política de reabrir en los
brazos de eeuu tomando una una actitud
más de más comprensión hacia aquellos
que buscan asilo político en eeuu
también ha presentado un proyecto de ley
que le abriría el camino para los 11
millones de ilegales que están en este
país o mejor dicho los cuales menor
palabra es los indocumentados aquellas
personas para que puedan tener un camino
hacia la ciudadanía
esa es propuesta de ley fue presentada
en el congreso y ahora entrará en debate
los republicanos se oponen abiertamente
a la propuesta pero
es un proceso de negociación que ya al
presidente bailén tomó el primer paso
ahora el expresidente donald trump
afirmó que la decisión de ello pretende
cancelar la seguridad fronteriza ha
lanzado por sí solo una crisis de
jóvenes migrantes que está enriqueciendo
a los contrabandistas y a los cárteles
criminales le pregunto si esta
afirmación es cierta
en la afirmación desde el tronco de que
se ha abierto el camino y que
efectivamente ha incrementado el número
de personas que están entrando a las
fronteras se han vuelto a abrir aquellos
campamentos pero con la diferencia que
se les está dando entrada junto a los a
los niños junto con sus familias no se
están separando como se estaba haciendo
en la era de tron el país tiene que
buscar una forma de normalizar el
proceso un país no puede tener fronteras
abiertas que dos todo el mundo
simplemente camine y entre ilegalmente
pero hay que hacerlo de una forma justa
y buscando el bienestar de aquellas
personas que entran para agrupar puestos
que ningún americano está dispuesto a
hacer y que después permanecen en el
país y son personas que no tienen
derechos y ayudan y contribuyen en la
sociedad con sus impuestos por lo tanto
si la situación de la migración es
necesaria para la economía americana hay
que buscar la forma justa para aquellas
personas que entren
tengan beneficios sociales y que
eventualmente puedan ser ciudadanos de
este país brevemente abogados hombre
aparecer un momento donde la
administración bardem tiene como
propósito unir el país y tratar de
mermar la violencia política cómo
influye ese discurso de trump en su base
más radical
el discurso del trono fue catastrófico
para la unión de eeuu para buscar la
unidad es lo que está buscando es una
minoría dentro del partido republicano
que lo apoye ciegamente y que más lo
mantenga vigente en el campo político
el discurso del ayer fue un discurso
extremadamente divisivo volvió a alegar
de que había sido le que le habían
robado la elección y propuso una cosa
que es la clave de todo esto más
importante del discurso mental desde el
punto de vista derecho que él pide que
las elecciones sean solamente un día un
día que las personas tengan que ir a las
urnas solamente aquellas personas que
estén seriamente enfermas que se les
permita votar y la razón de eso es que
el día martes que es el día de las
elecciones en el país es un día donde se
puede controlar solamente a aquellas
personas que están en mejores posiciones
tienen el tiempo para ir a las urnas y y
de esas formas y limitan la elección a
un solo día dejas fuera a millones y
millones de trabajadores que no puedan
ir a las urnas ese día
trump está buscando
y una forma autoritaria de que una
minoría se rija por estilos del país
abogado gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 feliz día
este lunes primero de marzo inicia
oficialmente el programa de vacunación
en uruguay justo cuando se cumple un año
de la toma de posición del presidente
luis lacalle pou el país sudamericano de
3.4 millones de habitantes comienza la
aplicación de las primeras dosis de la
china corona bajé en total han sido
confirmado cerca de 58 58 mil casos de
kobe y 19 en esa nación de los cuales
600 se han fallecido el informe se
daniel hablando
es el último país de suramérica en
iniciar la vacunación contra el joven de
a uruguay llegaron 192 mil dosis de
corona bag la vacuna elaborada por el
laboratorio chino sinovac y el personal
médico que estará a cargo de la
vacunación de la población general a
partir de este lunes fue el primero en
recibirla el gobierno estableció como
grupo prioritario al de trabajadores de
servicios esenciales docentes policías
bomberos y militares una semana después
el turno será para los profesionales de
la salud los residentes y funcionarios
de casas para adultos mayores así como
habitantes de refugios y cárceles y
quienes padecen de enfermedades crónicas
el cronograma termina con los demás
adultos mayores y el resto de la
población se espera que el 15 de marzo
se sumen otros 16 millones de dosis de
corona uac y para entre el 8 de marzo y
el 26 de abril se prevé la llegada de
460 mil dosis de país ser valiente que
de un total de 38 millones adquiridas a
esos dos laboratorios otros 15 millones
de vacunas provienen de la plataforma
kóvacs creada por la organización
mundial de la salud para distribuir
entre los países menos favorecidos
el plan nacional de vacunación coincide
con el primer año de mandato del
presidente luis lacalle pou el
mandatario pasó con relativo éxito su
primera prueba en el poder muchos vieron
adecuado su manejo de la crisis
sanitaria aunque algunos otros lo
critican por liderar un amplio recorte
presupuestal y hoy se espera que un
tribunal francés emita su veredicto
sobre el ex presidente nicolas sarkozy
por cargos de corrupción y tráfico de
influencias los fiscales alegan que
sarkozy se ofreció a asegurar un trabajo
en mónaco para él pues gilbert así bert
a cambio de información confidencial de
una investigación sobre las acusaciones
de que el ex mandatario había aceptado
pagos ilegales de la heredera de l'oréal
para su campaña presidencial del año
2007 vamos hasta el tribunal judicial de
parís allí está nuestra periodista
natalia ruiz natalia muy buen día que
sentencia se enfrenta hoy el ex
presidente sarkozy
buen día pues la audiencia debe estar
por comenzar dentro de unos pocos
minutos un proceso que duró cerca de un
mes que terminó a finales del año pasado
pero el veredicto solamente se da a
conocer hasta hoy en ese momento pues la
fiscalía financiera pidió penas de
cuatro años de cárcel dos de ellos se
firme tanto para nicolas sarkozy como
por su abogados y aliados o para quien
también pidió una prohibición de cinco
años de ejercer el derecho y la misma
pena también a para el ex magistrado así
viaja en realidad en la fiscalía pues
basso la mayoría de su caso en estas
escuchas de las conversaciones entre
sarkozy y su abogado diciendo pues que
ahí quedaba demostrado plenamente los
delitos que se habían cometido y por su
parte la defensa pues pidió que los tres
acusados fueran absueltos de todos estos
cargos y puso en entredicho
estas conversaciones telefónicas sobre
las cuales él basó su caso la fiscalía
explicando que se trata de una violación
del secreto profesional ya que se trata
de conversaciones entre un abogado y su
cliente en todo caso a la espera pues de
esta decisión que debe de darse a
conocer hoy pues todavía puede que este
proceso no termine ya que
nicolas sarkozy pues se ha condenado el
muy seguramente habrá de apelar esta
decisión esta vez habrá que empezar de
nuevo ante una corte de casación hasta
las gracias por información por supuesto
muy pendientes a lo que ocurra en este
caso lunes primero de marzo se conmemora
el día mundial del reciclado y
terminamos nuestra serie de reportajes
dedicada a esta población indispensable
pero invisible con la situación de los
recicladores en la ciudad de mexico en
la capital mexicana miles de personas
trabajan sin contrato y un salario fijo
este reportaje hace parte de la serie de
publicaciones resultados de la beca de
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusiva ejecutada con el apoyo de la
fundación gabo y la actitud ere nos
informa yanine quirós y claudia
altamirano
en la ciudad de mexico más de 10.000
voluntarios participan en el servicio de
recolección de basura de manera informal
el gobierno local les llama voluntarios
porque trabajan precisamente de manera
voluntaria y con eso justifican que no
les den contrato ni salario fijo pedro
es uno de ellos entre los residuos que
separa y revende y la propina que recibe
de los residentes de la ciudad gana
entre 10 y 12 dólares al día por
propinas bueno pues es que realmente es
variable
puede haber días que nos salga un poco
más a veces menos yo pero dependiendo
también de las posibilidades de la gente
pero hay otros recicladores que no
reciben propinas y sobreviven solo de la
venta de residuos al no tener contacto
con la población como patricia quien
trabaja en una planta de selección que
hay gente que design award call a
trabajar en la basura pero si supieran
que hay veces que nosotros que somos que
no tenemos en donde más trabaja somos de
donde nosotros tenemos y que si no
llegaran a cerrar oa quitar la basura ya
no a miles de personas se quedarían sin
trabajo los recicladores informales no
son reconocidos por las autoridades
locales lo único que obtienen de ellas
es el permiso para trabajar para esta
población marginada poder trabajar es el
único derecho que defienden que buscamos
con el gobierno pues que ahora que
tengamos la oportunidad de poder
trabajar que es lo esencial que es lo
que necesitamos hacer un funcionamiento
una labor aquí los recicladores
voluntarios
formales de la ciudad de mexico evitan
que casi 14 por ciento de los residuos
diarios vayan a rellenos sanitarios con
ello le ahorran al gobierno más de 6
millones de dólares al año según una
estimación a partir del inventario de
residuos 2019 un aporte ambiental y
económico que no es retribuido ni
reconocido en la ciudad más grande de
américa latina
hasta aquí el informativo de france 24
continúa con nosotros un día para todos
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio